thought it would be really cute to have
you guys do a valentine to each other
like what do you love the most about
Freddy and what do you love the most
about Sarah I'm gonna throw up on camera
yeah that's not our holidays I think
Valentine's is always so hard because if
you're single you feel really crappy
about it sorry and if you're with
someone it means more the other 364 days
a year when someone's not telling you to
say it yeah chocolate tonight you just
made every guy watch and go see see babe
just be like Sarah Michelle Geller you
should be more buy flowers needs 364
days a year 360. not on the 300 let's do
that to the fellas out there you know
how hard it is just tell your lady you
love them I think you could probably
like Postmates flowers now